[Applaudissements]
l'année dernière j'ai fait un voyage
dans le futur je suis parti pendant
trois jours en 2040 avec les albert
einstein et les marie curie de notre
temps nous sommes allés dans 22 ans au
pied de montparnasse le montparnasse en
grèce adelphe l'ancien centre du monde
chacun de ces explorateurs de génie
s'est présentée je les ai écoutés
attentivement
j'étais dans mon coin intimidé un peu et
il y en a un en particulier qui a retenu
mon attention
il s'appelle malek malek c'est un
chercheur c'est un conteur et c'est un
ultra marathonien de l'extrême ces gens
qui vont courir pendant des dizaines
d'heures sur des centaines de kilomètres
et qui parviennent à repousser leurs
limites
il nous a dit que chaque semaine quand
il s'entraînait pour un marathon il
allait courir au moins une fois pendant
une heure en marche arrière à l'envers
ça m'a frappé en fait ça m'a étonné
comme ça il peut travailler tous les
muscles inhabituels ou plutôt devant et
ça lui permet de ménager les muscles les
plus sollicités et de gagner en
performance
c'est contre intuitif j'ai adoré pour
penser la migration qui est mon domaine
c'est justement ça dont on a besoin
penser différemment innover aujourd'hui
le monde il est ouvert absolument tout
sauf les êtres humains seulement 3% de
la population mondiale vit dans un pays
autre que celui de son pays de naissance
la migration n'est plus l'usagé de nos
pieds c'est devenu un acte politique
qu'il faut justifier
là pour vous dire que la migration c'est
génial que c'est positif que c'est
formidable
j'ai failli foiré mon bac à cause de
trois étrangers rafael nadal novak
djokovic et rodger federer je connais
les dangers je suis simplement un
citoyen qui observe que 75% des murs aux
frontières en 2018 ont été créés depuis
les années 2000 alors que il ya un
siècle avant la première guerre mondiale
les frontières s'était simplement des
traces sur les cartes et qu'on pensait
que la nouvelle révolution technologique
le train à l'époque allait les faire
disparaître à jamais les sociétés
d'immigration au début du 21e siècle on
crée des murs et des escaliers dans
l'espoir de mieux maîtriser
l'incertitude et le changement
ces obstacles créés non seulement des
dangers pour les personnes qui bougent
et en plus ils n'ont pas l'effet
rassurant escompté mais du coup à quoi
ressemblerait un monde sans escaliers ou
sans mur nous avons déjà une petite idée
de ce que donnerait l'ouverture des
frontières ça s'appelle facebook et
après quatorze ans d'existence
voilà ce qu'il en ressort facebook for
good that connecting people
je suis d'accord avec marc l'enjeu
majeur du xxième siècle
c'est le lien c'est les connexions
positives en particulier entre des
personnes qui présentent des altérités d
altérité qui sont instrumentalisés dans
le débat public
je pense notamment à celle qu'on va
retrouver à la base du droit d'asile les
opinions politiques
la religion le sexe la couleur de peau
la classe sociale ou encore la
nationalité
aucune de ces altérité ne définit
l'identité d'une personne
ce sont des éléments du tout les
éléments d'une mosaïque qui constitue
une personnalité avec entre autres des
centres d'intérêt et des projets qui
vont évoluer dans le temps peu importe
l'altérité
il y aura toujours plus de commun cette
réalité
je l'observé nous l'observons depuis dix
ans qu'une travaillons à créer des
rencontres entre des personnes issues de
territoires différents dans une dizaine
de pays sur quatre continents
mais revenons dans le futur nous sommes
en 2040
le biomimétisme a révolutionné
l'industrie qui ne peut lui plus c'est
super il ya un ministère du bonheur
comme nous a dit charles les voitures ne
se conduisent toute seules et tourne à
l'électricité statique qu'on va chercher
dans le ciel la semaine de travail fait
15 heures et seulement quelques fous
travaille encore 17 18 ans nous avons
tous un potager les crypto monnaie ont
quasiment remplacer les monnaies qu'on
connaissait en 2010 8 mars est habité ou
pas on s'en fiche et surtout dès 2019 on
a vu l'arrivée du traducteur universel
qui a permis de faire complètement sauté
les barrières linguistiques et donc un
ami qui parle le swahili une amie qui
parle arabe peuvent communiquer avec un
troisième qui parlent français
c'est facile les néologismes sont
traduits les mots le jeu de mots en
instantané
au début des années 2020 nouvelle
révolution un nouveau type de réseau
social a vu le jour pour la première
fois nous étions connecter à des
personnes que nous n'aurions jamais
imaginé rencontrer ces millions de
rencontres vont forger au fur et à
mesure une nouvelle culture mondiale
plus collaborative qui va donner lieu à
un texte écrit par des citoyens partout
dans le monde
bottom up qui va redéfinir le cadre du
mouvement des êtres humains sur la terre
et qui va permettre de créer une
intégration horizontale
on crée des ponts enfin à nouveau et en
je me souviens la majorité des
frontières étatiques ont disparu pour de
bon favorisons un développement
économique à gruissan la création d'un
espace dans lequel chacun peut enfin
révéler son potentiel
si on ne court qu'avec les mollets et
les quadriceps tout le corps souffre si
on ne pense l'avenir de la migration
qu'en termes de protection humanitaire
sécuritaire c'est la même chose on se
prive de la contribution de l'économie
de l'éducation de la culture de tous il
est grand temps que nos sociétés
commencent à courir en arrière pour
solliciter tous les muscles de
l'humanité merci
[Applaudissements]